throughout goal there are two classes of
persons of definite account and dignity
as for the common folk they are treated
almost as slaves venturing naught of
themselves never taken into Council the
more part of them oppressed as they are
either by debt or by the heavy weight of
tribute or by the wrongdoing of the more
powerful men commit themselves in
slavery to the nobles who have in fact
the same rights over them as masters /
slaves of the two classes
above-mentioned one consists of druids
the others of knights
the former concerned with divine worship
the due performance of sacrifices public
and private and the interpretation of
ritual questions a great number of young
men gather around them for the sake of
instruction and hold them in great honor
in fact it is they who decide in almost
all disputes public and private and if
any crime has been committed or murdered
honor or there is any disposes about
succession or boundaries they also
decided determining rewards and
penalties if any person or people does
not abide by their decision they ban
such from sacrifice which is their
heaviest penalty those that are so
banned are reckoned as impious and
criminal all men move out of their path
and shun their approach in conversation
for fear they might get some harm from
their contact and though justice is done
if they seek it no distinction falls to
their share
of all these druids one is chief who has
the highest authority among them that is
death are there any other that is
preeminent in position succeeds or if
there be several of equal standing they
strive for the primacy by the vote of
the druids or sometimes even with armed
force these druids said at a certain
time of the year
meet within the borders of the carnutes
whose territory is reckoned as the
center of all gaul and sit in Conclave
in a consecrated spot the third symbol
from every side all that have disputes
and they obey the decisions and
judgments of the druids it's believed
that their rule of life was discovered
in Britain and transferred then Stigall
and today those who would study the
subject more accurately journey as a
rule to britain to learn it the druids
usually hold a loof from war and do not
pay war taxes with the rest
they are excused from military service
and exempt from all liabilities tempted
by these great rewards many young men
assemble their own motion to receive
their training many are sent by parents
and relatives report says that in the
schools of the druids they learn by
heart a great number of verses and
therefore some persons remain twenty
years under training and they do not
think it proper to commit these
utterances to writing although in all
most other matters and in their public
and private accounts they make use of
Greek letters I believe they have
adopted the practice for two reasons
that they do not wish the rule to become
common property nor those who learn the
rule to rely on writing and so neglect
the cultivation of memory and in fact it
does usually happen that the assistance
of writing tends to relax the diligence
of the student and the action of the
memory
the cardinal doctrine which they seek to
teach is that souls do not die but after
death pass from one to another and this
belief as the fear of death is thereby
cast aside they hold to be of the
greatest incentive to valor besides this
they have many discussions as touching
with stars and their movements the size
of the universe and of the earth the
order of nature the strength and the
powers of immortal gods and hand down
their law to the young man
[Music]
the whole nation of the Gauls is greatly
devoted to ritual observances and for
that reason those who are smitten with
the more Grievous maladies and who are
engaged in the perils of battle either
sacrifice human victims or vow to do so
employing the druids as ministers for
such sacrifices they believe in effect
that unless a man's life be paid the
majesty of the immortal gods may not be
appeased and in public as in private
life they observe an ordinance of
sacrifices of the same kind others use
figures of immense size whose the limbs
were one out of twigs they fill with
living men and set on fire and the men
perish in a sheet of flame they believe
that the execution of those who have
been caught in the act of theft or
robbery or some crime is more pleasing
to the immortal gods but when the supply
of such fails they resort to the
execution even of the innocent
[Music]
you
[Music]